botarga tô muito obrigado a todos portar
em campo sensoji fazerem parte da
extinção do texas que tem como tema
então por fora
queria agradecer pelo convite sinto
muito honrada em fazer quarto inicia
hoje e vocês por estarem aqui também são
zinha dos 30 desse uma salva de palmas
aos oradores xuxa tem feito
apresentações de excelentes mas agora
vamos vamos falar um caminho nós já
falamos isto rural do animal das plantas
das nossas organizações
vamos falar um carinho nós todos vocês
que estou a falar dos sonhos
eu sempre fui sonhadora desde a tenra
idade
sempre achei beleza nas quartas
sempre gostei de dança sempre está
enfiado sempre gostei de pintar e sempre
fiz questão que essas arte acompanhassem
até os 18 anos
o jogador 18 anos ele ainda antes de
mais não sabe o que é ou não sabiam era
não sabia o que eu queria
não sabia para onde eu ia não definiria
eu tenho uma bússola mas ela estava
completamente desnorteada
eu tentava mil vezes consultar a minha
semente a minha essência mas eu não
conseguia
simplesmente não sabia nunca tiveram em
situações em que vocês estão
deparado com vocês mesmo que você não
sabe o que aconteceu não sabem o que se
passou é pá e dizendo eu tô aqui mas eu
não sei o que aconteceu
sinceramente não sei quem eu sou
eu era assim todos os dias todos os
santos
e aí um belo dia eu tinha 19 anos e ele
só caiu deixando fazer é uma aula de
yoga e não é só por ainda estava em
londres e eu fui à minha primeira aula
de yoga pedal bastou estar nesta aula
o meu compasso a minha bússola começou a
fazer sentido
tudo pra mim e ao momento todas as cores
serão definidas exatamente com os mesmos
parâmetros
eu sabia exatamente o que eu queria eu
sabe exatamente para onde eu ia eu sabia
exatamente o que eu queria fazer com a
vida estava realizada pela flec andar a
map a quem procurava online
então eu decidi ok vou descartar abu sua
vou descartar aquela bull sua guiava
aquela busca quem definia aquela busca
como fazia consultar a minha essência
todos os dias porque eu sabia o que eu
queria
então eu descartei a bússola um belo dia
acordo
sou mulher sou casada tenho filhos tenha
sogra mas não sabia que eu era na sabia
exatamente o que eu queria não sabia
quem era não definia
e aí surge a minha filha e ok
ayew que foi a definição campo fez
buscar a minha bússola
eu encontrei a minha bússola qual a
questão 15 outra meu filho eu encontrei
a minha bússola qual é o que aí o que
feijão e novamente a minha essência aí o
que fez buscar ela fez modo descobrir o
universo dentro de mim porque nós
podemos olhar temos estrelas o seu
limite também o nosso universo dentro de
nós eu limito acredita em nós temos um
universo enorme dentro de nós
e antes de nós tentamos mudar aqui fora
nós temos que mudar dentro de nós
nós temos que nos amar muito
nós temos que nos prestigiar todos os
dias
então eu vou fazer um pequeno exercício
com vocês podem virar a vossa lateral
esquerda ou direita
eu irei fazer as três perguntas mais
difíceis da vossa vida
não canso
a primeira pergunta posso fazer a
primeira pergunta
a primeira pergunta você está com a mãe
a segunda pergunta posso
por que por que com você ia estar por aí
porque você está a correr mal
já o bota agora terceira pergunta então
frontera
essa é mais difícil gostariam com você
ia da manhã o respeito e depois de
amanhã ea próxima semana e o próximo ano
ok agora eu vou falar sobre algo muito
pertinente eu acho que cada um de vocês
que está já fez essa pergunta alguma vez
os meus alunos meus familiares as minhas
amigas
muitos perguntam célia o que é a
felicidade que eu não percebo é para eu
tenho casa tem um carro tem emprego tem
salário
tenho amigos meus familiares gozou
férias como os sapatos mas não sei o que
é a felicidade
a minha definição pessoal o que é a
felicidade
a felicidade e testeiras mãe a vossa
felicidade está na mente então qualquer
fator externo por ser instável por não
ser de origem vossa nunca vos vai trazer
felicidade nunca
quantas vezes nós dizemos a ele estou
chateado porque o meu chefe chapéu eu
estou chateada por comer bolos iphones
ou eu estou chateada porque sei lá o quê
os fatores externos têm definições
obscuras obs tratadas e não são
controlados pelo nosso ser logo nunca
irão trazer uma felicidade equilibrada
dentro de nós
a felicidade é do vosso controle
terceiro mãe tá dentro de vocês só vocês
podem definir isso eu estou chateada
reinaldo mas por estar chateada ou por
estar estressada qualquer coisa que seja
não defina se vocês tiverem interessados
se vocês tiverem chateados querem um
coffee break
aproveitem o momento
o vooz momento e agora vocês também são
sonhadores emotivo do tdf este mesmo
sairmos daqui com a nossa bússola
sairmos daqui com a nossa definição com
a nossa essência porque todos nós temos
uma essência e essência nos rodeia e
fino todos os dias e quanto mais nos
ombros mínimos mais nós traçamos os
nossos passos
concretizamos aqui exatamente o que nós
queremos ser
queremos viver quem não quer ver quem
não quer ser feliz
quem não quis realizar que não quer se
amar
então vamos com este louco vamos fazer
uma pequena meditação podemos ok eu vou
pedir que vocês sentem se confortáveis
fechem pouquinho fechem os olhos
e vou ter cá aspirem
lentamente
inspira enquanto e verei inspirar como
se tivesse inspiraram more por um fio
branco como se tivessem traria purificar
tudo que está dentro de vocês esse fosso
universo e eua inspirar como se vocês
tivessem aspirar todo o stress toda
pressão todo cansaço num fumo preto
xingu
concentrem-se plenamente na vossa
respiração
agora eu vos vou pedir uma coisa
tente imaginar o momento uma pessoa ou
um lugar como os faça muito feliz por
uma praia tentem sentir a idéia for uma
flor tentem sentir o cheiro
se for uma pessoa tenta imaginar o
sorriso o calor o perfume que essa
pessoa dá por trás quando está
acontecendo
agora eu vejo pouco desde que o foco em
a vossa atenção na sensação que essa
coisa lhe dar
sim esta sensação é mais ou menos a
vossa essência natural esta sensação é
que vocês devem parar todos os dias nas
vossas dificuldade nos rostos desafios
eles têm a vossa essência quando usarem
a vossa por sua festa é a vossa incenso
quer seja momento do pré sal quer seja
um momento de desespero
esta é a vossa excelência quer seja o
momento vasta dor
esta é a voz
os poucos podem abrir os olhos têm um
sonho
eu vos peço hoje tentei buscar a vossa
luz uma
encontrar a voz em 6
quebre as limitações dos vossos erros
quebre isso
quebre mesmo podem descer dos saltos e
procurem a voz e sem faço exatamente
você está fazendo os universos muito
obrigada